it's actually a series of satellites in
partnership with the US Geological
Survey and we have more than 50 years of
records of this and it can tell you
where there are trees where there are
crops um and we've worked you know with
people like the US Department of
Agriculture to identify which crops um
you can tell from space what's growing
by when it greens the precise color that
it is we can also we have other
satellites that can tell us about plant
Health um so we have one an instrument
on the International Space Station
called ecostress that it measures
temperature at this really really high
Precision um and what it turns out you
can learn from that is when plants are
water stressed so when plants don't have
enough water they get a little bit
hotter so they get a fever um and we can
see that from space